Oh welcome to another scintillating
episode of what's in the box man I'm
Todd Gerry
I guess what man we're gonna open the
[ __ ] out of this box suzi pulls a knife
out knifes out here comes the blade now
he's cutting it I even look I can see
that a lot of periphery of my eyes still
got it good boy what's it inside that
box Oh what is this oh no what is it
something that's gonna you're gonna want
to sit on it by the end of this show my
friend what is this so doing it if we
hold the rods and it shocks us and we
got a few can hold on longer whip cream
it slaps in the face unbox an episode of
[ __ ] laughing sock it to me okay man
this is a gateway drug this is a kids
game what is this electric shock
reaction game like we actually get hurt
playing this yeah featuring verbal shot
control what's your aggression face it's
not for voice it's not for kids my
friend it's meant for ages 14 plus the
idea of this game as you can see
depicted on the box here is to inflict
pain on others I'll be honest with you
I'm an utter [ __ ] me so I put it as low
as possible because I don't want to cry
on the show that'd be so weird what are
you breaking it for we should probably
go to the combustible [ __ ] way far away
from this if it's truly ok we're
supposed to hold this now yes now it
says number of players and what do you
put co2 Greens yeah but remember we have
to press the button don't touch it I
want to us number of players so we
choose that's three four no - we got -
all right and we put our thumbs on the
button but we don't yes down so stick
armwrestling almost all right so we're
gonna not like arm wrestling at all no
all right here we go and press this
button right there it arms the device
yes then when you see it get green or
turns green you press your button yes if
you're right you won't get shocked I
will if you're wrong you will get
shocked all right let me say the highest
is four let's put it on - here we go you
ready for this
[Applause]
[Music]
don't [ __ ] me on this dude - did you how
did you win how did you get that on
green I hit that sucker all right let's
do it again that's it we gotta do it
till you get shot all right is it
because you gotta have fun that's what
fun is we won't get hurt
yes here we go ready yeah shocks me and
I didn't even try that's unfair did you
know I hit the but don't look at this
one
all right you don't you can't look okay
look you're not looking [ __ ] up it
feels weird
the inventor and electrician George
Mathias Bose would wire up a woman and
invite male guests to kiss her when
they'd lean in they get a zap on the
lips that's where this game came roll I
mean that's going a long way for a prank
you know this guy's like gonna wire you
up and when somebody comes to kiss you
we're gonna laugh if she's pretty and
the guys are coming up and they're like
oh I'm gonna get something to say this
was that a 1740s party we're talking
about so I don't think anybody in the
1740s is that kind they get done before
the Revolution I think that was that but
that's how old this [ __ ] is not this
particular ship but shocking people for
fun and [ __ ] pleasure that's probably
a Ben Franklin thing right he discovered
electricity so he's probably hey George
I'm doing it to everybody right now
let's do the real man version
turn all the way up to four you know
what if we were a real hardcore
we would each hold two like either way
you're getting shocked you know what I'm
saying that's the fun part of the game
or one guys getting two shocks and if
that dude passes out the other dude gets
put at balls on his mouth take a picture
oh that's the rules okay what we gonna
do never gotta set it for four players
all right so all of them are armed
farmed this is awesome so now this means
that we're getting shocked regardless
yes but only one hand is not gonna get
shot okay
here we go ready ready I'm gonna press
it now arm the weapon
[Music]
that's [ __ ] up
did you feel it no I hit it both hands
it was a cow that's not it blue is the
child's - wait this is crazy and the
funnest thing I've ever had I'm taking
this home
oh my god I'm with the dog so I'm just
gonna hook it up to the dogs hit me like
they don't have thumbs
I'm gonna win every [ __ ] time the
wife and the kid did you do it the
greatest invention of all time I
understand the cellphones important but
Jesus reloaded thumbs up man [ __ ]
leech I said factoids goddamn I still
feel it a little factoid I was reading
it says if you put it in your barn hole
and get shocked you can have a multi
orgasm well it certainly fit its place
fit for you can I get in you're gonna
want to sit on it by the end of this
show my friend this goes into the
sphincter this cups the balls and then
you play the game and that kids is how
you play reloaded I'm sure the reloaded
people don't want you playing the game
that way but when you're drunk you know
I will the [ __ ] let's play reloaded that
you play - anal reload as long as you do
kegels you're gonna be a winner every
time
lady lady think this is the greatest
thing that ever happened to the show we
get every episode we should take one of
these out of the box bring someone on
the show and make them [ __ ] do it
this could actually go like in your man
cave and it looks sci-fi is right it
does look badass you wouldn't have to
defend this time people like what's that
and you look what's that that's metal is
what it is much it alright I love that
ass music - you know what I'm saying
like I would just listen to that even
I'm playing the game in my car like
driving through the hills
[Music]
the electric shock lightning reaction
game what a perfect [ __ ] name for it
retail price what would you pay for this
because I'll tell you right now I mean
look it's portable it's [ __ ] works
let's got moving parts electric and [ __ ]
like that what would you pay for that
how it saves over twenty eight ninety
nine dick I'd pay like 70 bucks or
something is sweet fun we're gonna have
shock and [ __ ] out of people with that
said what you would pay I'm thinking
retail price they're only asking 35 90
oh it's 29 now that's a lot of [ __ ]
confidence in that product and they
should be because nothing works better
than this man
we've already [ __ ] had so much fun
but let's check this out bro 5 face game
retails for $19.99 then one of the most
popular hard to get toys of Christmas
2015
yes sir you put the whipped cream on the
hand then each player puts their face in
the hole oh this is like the glory hole
game you take this to a bathroom a blur
I hope I win kids sometimes in life they
tell you right on the box
squirty cream not included so bring your
own surge to popularity after a video of
a man playing with his grandson went
viral on YouTube ok man it's got a
spinner so you know it's a game let's
see what the directions are put some
delicious squirty cream not included
from home on a wet sponge
squirty cream and wet sponge is no way
to open a kid's game it's an adult's
game best hey kids use your squirty
cream don't forget to include a sponge
otherwise you'll have a baby alright so
what you do is you spin yeah and and
that'll tell you how many cranks you do
alright so yeah hit the cream on we do
like I'll do that fat man knows that
handle whipped cream trust me alright to
do with it you probably took try to take
a whipping it off it me I [ __ ] know
you put this on a desert and it's non
dairy dessert topping alright here we go
[Music]
you gotta make it a pig
[Applause]
alright alright get your face in there
I'm gonna spin for you ready five five
cranks ready one two mmm I don't think
that's a crane oh I don't think that's a
crime
it can't be a full crank you gotta be
alright here we go the whole point no
but we had to go back and forth no no no
this is fine
remember the playing me like agreeing to
that at all three cracks three cracks
one two that went viral but that's crazy
in a world where on the internet you can
watch videos of [ __ ] people having
sex with horses a video of a grandpa and
a kid doing this went viral
i tender especially more of a smack it
just meant I think we use a little too
much whipped cream okay I think I may
have broken the device we brought out
some other stuff instead I'm suggesting
guacamole oh I don't know like yeah we
could set up a scene where you're like
you're at we're like Chipotle or Baja
Fresh a hose tacos there you go Danny
Trejo's tacos so you're there and you've
just complained to Danny Trejo about his
tacos not having enough guacamole yes
that's the scene cuz you know what
happens when you could plan to Trejo
about not having oh yes all right
all right now we know the rules of the
game you twist until it puts it in your
face
which is what we play at home without
this game ready yeah I don't like these
tacos mr. Trejo
I don't like it on
now a spring action on it you're not
it's like there's like yeah that's as
hard as Danny Trejo gets them I would
feel free to complain about the
blackmail exactly okay with some sour
cream okay let's do it man we're halfway
there to a Mexican feast this is a
fiesta I feel like I'm out of kids
you're already on the fingertips now
okay maybe playing it with a little bit
of extension there that's true that's
what we wanted flying across the room
all right here we go man you've gone to
the taco joint and you're like I didn't
get enough sour cream on this I have one
question for you um you know any music
how do you like eating that guacamole
fool and I was like whatever dude you
ain't so tough
[Music]
good lord
ah it's fun but it's not as fun as this
you know what would be even good times
we can add to this we combine the two
you get shocked and there's a big fist
here that just throws we could do that
right now here we go
you put your hands on these okay you
take two of them turn this bad boy on
get her activated you got to put your
face in this as well we'll just put the
light dusting having a really know when
a little bit of this when when the
actual thing's gonna go off at the same
time I don't know no I don't know weird
unchartered territory here Matt I got
this ready here we go
[Music]
[Music]
boy that was fun man
I bet you'd like to see us pull more
things out of boxes and put them
together Frankenstein them and have them
blow up in our faces but cream on us and
stuff like that we won't know unless you
let us know so right to the screen
junkies they tell us everything they
filter our mail I haven't heard from my
wife in a long time as they read and
redact all of our mail right to them
screen jockeys Twitter or Facebook or at
this address right below and tell them
what you would like to see us open up
we're at an end children I've been Kevin
Smith chasing you and in the Box this
week was a [ __ ] on a metric [ __ ] up
[Music]